yeah you know as I was going up in the
hood you don't mean becoming a gang
member from my hood because all my
family were gang members my brothers and
sisters my little brother you know
coming up in the hood you know I wanted
to be what they call it the hood star
because of the fact that you know we had
a lot of homies from the hood and a lot
of them did a lot of treacherous things
you know some of them rob banks we had
we had a crew of bank robbers we had a
crew of drug dealers and then we had a
crew of dudes it wouldn't work you know
all the type of individual where you
know I don't want my older homies to get
at me and tell me hey you know you ain't
putting in the work you know I mean you
ain't doing what you're supposed to do
you know I didn't really want them to
tell me anything when all the homies
came I got it to a point where at age of
15 I was doing things that my homies
were 21 and 25 they were doing because
the fact that you know I got schooled by
a lot of older cats and my neighborhood
where I'm from which is come to run-ins
you know we're real involved with a lot
of with a lot of [ __ ] you know I mean
we're involved with a lot of you know
stuff like uh you know um we're like the
number one gang in the southeast for a
long long time we had the most big
homies which are you know the guys in
charge and then we were you know
destined to run the area for many many
years but like when I was 15 years old
we had maybe like seven youngsters and
what happened was you know we went
through one summer and everybody got
busted everybody was busted I was the
only one out there by myself you know me
and I was going at it with maybe like
three or four different gangs
I was getting shot at every weekend you
know I can remember occasions where I
was walking into the Denny's one time I
turned around and I got shouted me seven
times point blank range missed me you
know shot at me inside Denny's you know
the cops came I took off running being
you know back to my hood and you know I
knew this guy that shot at me seven
times and I was only 15 years old you
know I already got shot at like nine
times nine different occasions but
there's one occasion I got shot at
Denny's you know it was really really
close you know and that was like the
first time that I really wanted to pick
up a gun you know so I wanted a gun and
I didn't care where it came from what it
had on it you know it didn't matter you
know but I was young I end up pain I
think it was $40 for a 22 revolver
there's real small guns but I remember I
got it you know I cleaned all the
bullets off I loaded up my gun I was 15
years old it was maybe about 1989 maybe
1990s old things were really popping in
the hood while I was by myself you know
on one day I'm kicking it you know I'm
by myself and I'm thinking you know my
homies are getting shot left and right
my older homies get shot left and right
and I'm the only youngster out there and
you know the pressures on me you know
it's on you know what am I gonna do one
thinking what am I gonna do you know I
was already selling PCP and I was only
15 years old but I used to hide my PCP
inside of three coconuts that my
grandmother brought from Hawaii you know
she used to smell it because it was
these three coconuts she used to sit on
top of her TV and the coconut the head
used to unscrew so I started school
ahead and put all my bottles of juice
inside the coconut can close it up my
grandfather my grandmother used to be
sweeping and she could smell the PCP but
she didn't actually know what I was
coming from what was coming from what
was coming from the top of her TV inside
the coconut so like I asked it there for
months I said dude you know deal dope
out of her house see my grandmother you
know she knew everybody from the hood
all my uncle's were from the hood you
know meaning I remember I came home one
day and my grandmother stopped me at the
door you know and she's like uh you know
I hear you're carrying a gun you know
when I 115 and I I didn't lie to my
grandmother I told her more days yeah so
what happened with my grandmother you
know and she searched me down she'd grab
my gun and she'll put it away and I was
hard to get my gun but due to the fact
that I had a younger uncle that was from
my hood you know sometimes my
grandmother would take his drugs and I
knew where these drugs were I also knew
where the needles rat you know the one
that used heroin you know they wanted me
to get needles my grandma was diabetic I
knew where all the needles was that
because I was a youngster so I used to
go get their needles before I give them
their needles I used to want back my gun
so I said someone okay where you go get
my gun I'll get you the Negroes get you
whatever you want from grandma's house
because we also have what they call
black box and that black box was stuff
in there that was doing the truth my
uncle because he was in the feds doing
time the black box nobody was able to
touch that box no one's ever gonna get
money out of there you know you could
put money in but you can never take
nothing out you know and next to that
black box sad the rigs and everything
else that my grandmother used to hold so
he still sneak in there go in there and
get him and then give my uncle rigs and
he would give me back my gun I would
give him back these drugs so I did that
for like a good summer you know and then
the end of the summer was coming up like
three of my homies had got killed you
know and I was out there puttin in work
you know I was putting in work putting
in work sometimes I would do things out
there where I would come home and I
wouldn't want to leave for like two or
three days because I was afraid of what
I did I was there you know saying some
things idea out there were the world
very very treacherous you know a 15 year
old shity to see things like this but
due to the fact that I grew up in a gang
member in a gang banging family you know
I knew right and wrong for the beginning
you know the only thing that I didn't
know was I was so young that I will
always brandish my gun
I was brandish my gun I would show
people my gun show people my gun and my
older homies were getting at me like
amen
that's not what it's for but I was so
young and I would keep brushing my gum
and she my gun well what happened was is
that I had my gun on me and we were
kicking back in my hood and were like 1
million one out one apartment street is
damn being bluej in my hood and it's
kind of you know it's kind of difficult
to get in and out of there because the
fact that streets are so small that we
used to box people in but at this time I
was selling PC
and people were coming from everywhere
to buy PCP I had it bumper-to-bumper in
the hood where people would smoke and
just get stuck right there they'd smoke
a Dipper and their girlfriend would end
up getting naked the coffee calm you
know I mean and I was only 15 years old
you know people would knock at my door
to 3:00 in the morning
my grandmother would answer and they
would say hey I want 20 did you know and
I get in trouble because my grandmother
knew that I was dealing PCP but she was
asking me you know are you dealing PCP
because people are coming to 3:00 in the
morning like my older homeboys and
homegirls would come and they'd be all
spaced out on that PCP and they'd come
and say yeah give me a 20 and they'd be
asking my grandmother my grandmother
going in garage up my ass real quick and
they tell me he wants you outside so I
go outside and dildo you know I did
several things out of my house I got a
bulb out of my house I've shot it people
in my house you mean I I don't know one
time I came home
well what time I went out during the
streets in I was out there gangbang
I ain't have seen this guy from the
enemy hood and I seen him in his car I
drove up on him broke all these windows
shot at him like three times I got away
I went in partying at my homies house
well the next morning when I came home I
seen my grandfather in the front yard
and you're kind of mad so I walked up he
got a big old stick that he had cut off
a tree and he peeled it down with his
knife he sanded it and she lacked it and
then let it sit in the Sun and let it
dry it was from my ass but I didn't
actually know why he was so upset so
when I get home he tells me hey what the
hell's going on here you know somebody
shot the house last night come here in
the front yard so he took me to the
front yard and in front of the house
he's showing me the halls and showed me
one hose and he goes looked at that damn
hole you don't so I looked through the
hall and he says you see what I see and
I'm looking on living is I'm like nycos
the [ __ ] dogs I played in the
backyard and I'm in the front yard so in
other words from the front yard I looked
through my house and I could see the
hole that went all the way through my
house all the weights in my backyard
where the dogs were playing so my
grandmother you know my grandfather you
know he what my ass would last and you
know my grandfather used to think that I
was the only one
all his grandsons and his sons that
didn't go out and do the deed because I
was the type of individual that if I did
something I kept it to myself because I
felt that if you talk about it it's like
doing it all over again so my
grandmother schooled me when I was a
youngster you know she taught me how to
read people you know she taught me up
more or less how to be a man you know I
mean I was made by a woman and raised by
a woman and you know she schooled me in
in every fashion you could think of you
know me when she's I used to go do
missions you know my grandma used to ask
me you know don't go with anybody go by
yourself you're gonna do it by yourself
only you could tell on yourself so I
grew up in the gang environment yes my
grandmother my grandmother gave me
advice due to the fact that my
grandmother had like seven sons that
were gang members yeah she had one son
that was you know one of those guys from
the mob you know he was my uncle and
that was her son so she knew all the ins
and outs of gang name you know when I
lost my mother and my mother and father
when I was a child my father was from my
neighborhood he was big Casper I'm
little Casper my mother was out of
normal walk but they got together had me
and my brothers and sisters and I knew
in the beginning of life when I used to
go to my grandmother's for Christmas and
Thanksgiving I knew eventually that me
and my little brother were gonna be from
this gang that was so in tithing inside
my family I lost my parents at the age
of 13 I was already kicked out of school
I got caught with an ounce to eat at
school I was about 12 years old they
gave me what you call independent study
independent study you know you take your
books home from school do the work and
then you mail it back in well it was
about middle of June and me and my
mother and my father and my aunt and my
niece were walking coming from the bus
stop we were walking across the street
we only had to cross three streets and
we would be at my house we could see my
house from the bus stop but what
happened was we were crossing the street
and it was my mother me in the middle
and my aunt on the side of me and then
my dad and my with my niece on his
shoulders and he
friend why I remember the light turned
green and said walk so we started
walking across the street all I felt was
a hit in my chest when I fell back I
seen the truck go by he struck my mother
first my mother went up in the air he
hit my aunt my aunt went under the truck
he kept going my mother fell back on the
hood rolled off the hood and he ran her
over with the back tires all along my
aunt was stuck under the truck her arm
was stuck in the wheel shaft and when
this guy stopped maybe about 80 feet he
was still trying to take off but he
couldn't take off because my aunt's arm
was stuck inside the wheel shaft now I
remember my father was running from my
mother to my hand back and forth and you
know they got hit by that truck and it
kind of like ripped their clothes when
my father was trying to cover my mother
go to my aunt he was going back and
forth back and forth back and forth and
then we lived right across the street
and my older brother and sister he came
running out the house my aunt was dead
on the scene my mother died on the way
to the hospital now when my mother died
you know they took us in this little
room in the hospital and they told my
father that what happened to my mother
my aunt now I didn't know what my father
was thinking but my father took us
inside the room where they tried to save
your life and then you die they leave
you in a room and you know they should
leave you on a gurney so he took us in
inside there and it was one of the most
gruesome his sights I've ever seen in my
life you know my aunt more than
side-by-side they still had the two
plastic tubes in their mouths where they
were trying to give them oxygen but they
were just filled all going to the top of
blood you know you couldn't even
recognize land my mom from the body
means so bruised it battered from that
truck that hit him so once the truck hit
him you know we automatically he never
went back to that house my father told
us no one's going back to this house
someone's going to step in this house
you know we're gonna leave it just the
way it is so I was like okay you know my
father was my best friend you know and
then about two weeks passed and my
father started telling me that he
couldn't
except what had happened and I follow my
best friend sweet she's showing me
everything so one night about for about
a month after it happened he turns
around he tells me before he loves TV
telling me tomorrow I'm gonna kill
myself and the way he told me was more
or less that he was gonna check out
those are the words he used he told me
i'ma check out and I was already from my
hood there tunes I kind of knew what he
meant but I begged my father all night
not to kill himself but I knew he had
his mind made up the only thing I had
asked him was why did you come to this
conclusion that even want to be on
another was not earth anymore you know
you're gonna leave him to me and my
brothers you're gonna leave me my little
brother who's gonna take care of us he
shifted all of my bolder brother he said
your older brother could take care of
you and I said yeah but he's not my dad
you know you're my dad you know I kind
of was upset with him a long time
because we've seen the same thing and I
live with the image in my head the same
way he lived with the image in his head
for a long time I was upset my father
because he did kill himself what he
actually did the next day was he when it
picked up about two grams of heroin he
went to his best friend's house he told
his friend to go to the bathroom and get
some Cotton's or something he grew up to
full ribs of heroin and slam both of
them they couldn't even save him my
mommy's sister was a registered nurse
she was there at the house when it
happened she tried to save my father but
he was dead and he killed himself 30
days exactly after my mother got killed
but he had told me not to tell anybody
so I kept that secret for 20 years I
never told anybody
that my father was gonna kill himself I
didn't tell his mother I didn't tell my
brothers and sisters I didn't tell
nobody my father was my best friend you
know he more or less confided in me and
he wanted me to hold that and I held it
for a lot of years you know when I did
come out with it eventually my half my
family stopped talking to me they
stopped talking you for the simple fact
that they said I knew and I should have
told him but you know my father told me
and confiding said I was gonna keep it
to me you know and the only
understanding is we've seen the same
thing
one guy told me well that one one one
time before a guy asked me if I knew
what hell was and I told him yeah you
know fire brimstone
everything you read the Bible he's like
no because I want you to do something
for me he tells me close your eyes so I
close mine he goes picture the most
horrifying gruesome esteem you've ever
seen so I'm thinking goes you got it and
I said yeah I got it I pictured my
mother and my aunt getting killed in
front of me now remember I was walking
with my mother and my aunt my mother
pushed me out the way and the car killed
her and my aunt the car was supposed to
also kill me so my mother saved my life
but I used to see the whole thing
transpire right in front of me because
it happened in front maybe four feet in
front of you when the truck hit my
mother my hand and he hit him very hard
the guy was driving a school district
truck he ran in that red light on his on
his lunch break he was drinking they
only give the dude three years
he killed my aunt my mom he only got
three years he didn't get her drunk
driving he just got vehicle manslaughter
but it was an accident which he ran a
red light yeah my family sued you know
for that and me my god my brothers and
sisters we you know we got a settlement
you know we had a lot of time you know I
mean and you know but it doesn't mean
the fact that it brings back my mother
but the thing about it was is the way I
remember my mother is I never heard of
cus they used to call her sister Mary
she went to church three times a week so
I wasn't you worried about where my
mother went when she passed on because I
knew she was going with we should
believed in but now my father's case was
something totally different you know he
was my homie he was a heroin addict he
had tattoos he ran around the hood
we drank a lot of thunder burn and I
remember I used to wake up in the
morning with him and he used to get 85
cents for a pack of Camel not put your
cigarettes 98 cents for a bottle of
Thunderbird t-bird
you know he's get a bottle of that and
then he used to get $25 for what they
call the GU Chadha a spoon and heroin
but back then I remember my father his
name is heroin and he'd only Sam one
time of day just in the morning and he
would be set the whole day nowadays you
cannot you have to sign like get busy
like five six times a day you got to
inject it like five six times back when
I used to see him he used to get one
spoon $25 and he used to last him all
day you know so all to my life my father
was a heroin addict and my mother didn't
even use drugs I guess you could say
opposites attract but I should see my
father come home sometimes bloody
sometimes drunk sometimes high on heroin
he's old Pete a few times you know but
him and my mother were opposites but
when my mother got killed my father
couldn't accept the fact that he was
gonna be here alone but the one mistake
he made was he had told us nobody went
back to the house the house even as is
the way my mother had it and everything
nobody went back but he messed up and he
went back by himself he said that he
went back to the house and he laid in
the bed and him and my mother laid him
for 20 years and he said he felt lonely
he couldn't take it without her you know
I tried everything in the book to have
him not kill himself but I came home
from school the next day and I was at
the park with my homies I was already
animated so we're running my smoking bud
and I remember my aunt came in her VW
and she was crying and she wanted us to
get in the car and I didn't want to get
in the car you know when she looked at
me she thinking the car need to tell you
something I tell her I already know my
father's dead she looked at me and
wonder how I knew but my father had
already told me previous that he was
gonna kill himself I just didn't know
exactly what day he waited 4:30
exactly and he killed himself on that
day so I lost my mother one month then I
lost my father in the next month so me
and my little brother were worried about
who's gonna raise this that's when my
grandmother stepped in and took the
rings and rings me and my little brother
mind effect that she already had raised
seven sons and all of them were from the
hood except one of them she had just
finished with the youngest one was like
23 years old but me and my little
brother we moved into my grandmother's
house and we knew that this was the
starting of our gang life you know
because my own business attendants their
clothes and we used to dress up because
my grandmother wouldn't buy a snow game
we made it close now for the first year
we knew she's the bias tight-ass jeans
tight shirt she wanted to dress
different and my uncle's weren't
allowing that you know because my
uncle's were prepping me and my little
brother to be the next ones from the
hood along with maybe four or five of my
cousin's there was about eight of us
total from the family that were young
and we were from the hood but my uncles
were prepping me and my little brother
to be you know who just say may be the
most treacherous youngsters within our
hood and at that time me and my little
brother were we were put in the most
work we had the most dudes at ducking
and dodging I mean girls used to tell us
in their hood when they heard we were
coming they were going stash they were
going hide you know sometimes we weren't
even going over there but we were just
putting in so much work that every
little a lot of us were fearing us we
wanted to be a hood star well my little
brother told me one time as he said he
goes I'm kind of upset with God you know
and I was like okay I understand over
what do you mean he's like anything God
took my mom and my brother was the
favorite of my mother he said yeah I got
took my mom you know he tell me why
don't we uh try to overpopulate heaven
you know
I was like what I thought I heard him
wrong and I said what did you say he's
like let's all [ __ ] let's overpopulate
heaven this is impossible you can't do
that you know me my little brother went
on the Spree were off on our records
we've been picked up or like seven hot
ones together you know and separate ones
but you know me my little brother used
to put in a lot of work and my little
brother had the mentality that he
actually thought that he is gonna
overpopulate heaven you know he went to
why he was 14 years old for attempted
murder
you know meaning he got back out and we
ran the streets again and you know we
lived in my grandmother's house and my
grandmother's house was like the main
spot for our gang you know people used
to come there to visit her you know come
drop off things from Monaco people used
to go with money go need you know food
dope and my grandmother was like the
main grandmother from the hood you know
I mean and they used to call her Big Al
she was also United parents back then
they had a United parents where they
used to get in the gangs and get the
girls and guys and they would buy them
jerseys and they would play softball and
she did that for like about ten years
you know and I remember I was I was
growing up as a youngster I actually
seen my uncle's at my aunt's petting
softball you know meaning I always was
in my hood all the time you know and my
family there was seven of my hands and
seven of my uncles and I think one of my
aunt's in one of my uncle's wasn't from
the hood but the rest work and all their
kids so I was like a third generation in
my family the next generation was my
childhood my daughter was from my hood
also but we got prepped in a fashion
where when we were 19 years old we got
sat down the first thing we were told
it's never tell you know we were taught
we're embedded in us that never tell him
never call the cops you know I called
the cops one time because my car got
stolen but it took me three hours just
to pick up the phone and call him
because I
called the cops I was always a 1/2 G I
am the cops there's something rap on my
family or so it would take days with us
I would take care of it I wouldn't call
the law I was the law I had a gun just
like them but I wouldn't have to abide
by rules like that you know I mean and
my family once I turned 16 I was a sole
provider for my whole family
so grab growing up in my grandmother's
house you know we knew the booze to go
by when we needed to be in you know and
a lot of times when my mother and father
were died there was time to me my little
brother wouldn't even come home for two
days and we were like 19 10 years old
attending in Devon years old we got to
my grandmother's it was the same way
because the fact that her house was open
like all night you know I remember they
used to play poker on her table turn on
her friends a couple mines and uncles
and they should be like ten of them you
know and then we used to go in through
the backdoor and sneaking Queen or
sneaking in guns you know my grandmother
used to wake up in the morning
and she used to walk around the yard and
she was just guns one time I see her
walking with like six guns two rifles a
shotgun and she collected these just out
of our yard at home because we should
set the guns by you know by the bricks
by bush you know because people used to
shoot at our house all the time so we
used to always shoot back as we got a
little older we started realizing how my
uncles were doing it when it's that's
the gun is where they stash the dope if
my house was really really active we
used to get raided a lot you know the
FBI was on my family because of my
uncles and affairs and he was doing this
thing and you know it's really really
heat on my house but at the same time we
used to put in a lot work we used to go
do a lot of things to a lot of people
you know we used to break windows in
people's houses we start old cocktails
at people's houses you know would fill a
bottle for gas put a fuse in there light
it and throw it on people's cars but I
didn't realize until later in life that
look at me better than she looked at
anybody else you know kind of figure she
was always on me you don't mean but she
always did tell me things like I
remember one time I was in jail and I
called home and I asked my grandmother
about my uncle cuz she told me that she
had got a letter from my uncle and I
told her oh yeah you know how is he
doing he had had 399 years with a life
sentence to the feds how many years 399
with a life sentence my uncle he's one
of those guys but he had yeah 300 years
399 years will I like sitting on top of
that and he was in that he was in Miriam
illinois' 3 floors underground you know
I mean and you know he was real real of
treacherous guy and I remember I called
her on the phone one time from jail and
I asked her you know how does he look
she said we must all get MAS and my
grandmother just answered the question
with like a straight killer what else do
you think now I knew what my family was
about when my grandmother answered that
question I asked her how was her son and
she said boy he looks like a real killer
what do you think now coming from my
grandmother talking about her son like
that I knew what type of family I was
involved with when I heard that out of
my grandmother's mouth because that's
her own son for her to say he looks like
a straight killer what else do you think
showed me that my grandmother knew what
time it was all the way around you know
I mean she was they said about your son
takes a lot but my grandmother was just
stating oh my uncle he was because as I
was growing up also my grandfather
fooled around on my grandmother my
grandmother found out and jumped in
front of a car she tried to kill herself
in other words what mom who found out my
uncle same word back to my grandmother
if she wanted her husband took out now
that's coming from his son you know and
I caught winter because I was there and
I heard
conversation and I got my gun saying
that her son got Anna asked her if he
would take out his own dad due to the
fact that his dad was fooling around on
his mother so then I knew what time it
was my uncle I just found out how my
grandmother was but now I thought how my
uncle was so I knew I had to tread
lightly when I did things in my
neighborhood I knew I had to keep my
mouth shut
you never say a word to the cop I mean
ask for lawyer just hush up don't say
[ __ ] you know me because they say SS up
from A to Z you know why I don't go that
showed me how to do this I had an uncle
show me how to do this one show me how
to do drugs when showed me how to take
guns apart one told me how Jail was
gonna be you know I already knew that I
was destined for prison all my family
knew they weren't destined for prison
because the fact that that's the way it
went
juvenile ha-joon our camp why I hate
prison and we all went through little
steps and you know we used to have
get-togethers at my house at my
grandmother's house and that's when all
my family was together and I would see
all my uncles you know they had frogs on
I'm you know even from the hood 20 30
years and you know I used to look at him
and I used to idolize him you know I
used to watch the way the Iguazu kind of
clothes they wore you know kind of drugs
they did I wanted to be just like them I
had nothing else in life I didn't want
to be a lawyer I didn't wanna be a cop I
don't wanna be a fireman no I wanted to
be a children I wanted to wear a hairnet
I wanted to wear big old pants where you
missed the first buckle you go to the
second book on bring him in I used to be
like I still have a way it's like the 26
ways and I used to wear like a fight a
size 48 levites now the 48s are really
really big you know I mean I used to
miss the first buckles and pull him from
the second buckles and we're talking
about size 48 pants Levi's I used to
wear that you should wear maybe like a
2x sweater you know that's the last of
the troubles that were hearing it was my
generation
used to wear a hairnet a beanie you mean
I already have my chair drop on my face
so you know we're gang-related from were
very very young I remember exactly when
I got in my hood goes the summer of the
seventh grade you know we had just got
out of school you know a summer time we
got bored and we were like we're running
around all these cities and they all
buddy had youngsters we didn't even have
youngsters I think the youngest guy for
my little was 20 to me so me and my
little brother and my homies we started
my hood back to life now we tried strong
or one of the most deepest in South East
LA
there's a lot of us but back then there
was only seven youngsters and we took on
the role of keeping the hood of life so
we kept the good of life I know everyone
all of us seven I know their name where
they were from I grew up with these guys
and maybe out of seven of us there was
only two of us that are still active the
rest a couple of them died cuz when
we're doing life and a couple of we just
gave up they don't want no part of
nothing anymore
and I respect that you know I think I'm
the only one now that's still active I'm
46 years old and I'm still active I
don't mean I'm out there gang banging
and shooting at people but you know I
gotta be careful because along the way I
know I made a lot of enemies I might not
be an enemy of this guy that's gaming in
his hood today but I might shot his
brother when I was a youngster I might
put in work in my homies but he smoked
one of his brothers so he's taking it to
heart in these situations where I seen a
dude and he was killing I don't even
know this guy next thing I find out that
I stabbed his brother when I was 17
years old this was 20 years ago but due
to the fact that I did some harm to
somebody's family it still runs in the
blood you know so I got to be careful
these days
when right here in downtown or walking
the streets I got to be careful that
some youngsters are just coming from
behind and cap me shoot me in the back
of the head because I did something to
his brother previous also I used to be
with a lot of women and I had a lot of
problems like that with their boyfriends
their brother
because I should be women that were from
enemies in mind because I just want to
pump up for information one of them
uncle screwed me in that fashion he said
if you want information on somebody
else's hood be with your homegirls
they'll tell you everything about their
hood and sure enough that's what I did
but also I've been set up seven times by
women I've been stuck in a house where
they surrounded the whole house and the
only way I heard him was I heard I was
laying with this girl and I heard
outside window she's inside I heard this
through the window now I remember
previous this girl and showed me her
dad's Mossberg shotgun that he had in
the closet so what I did was I went in
the closet grab the Mossberg cocked it
went to the front window and shot one
time out the front window by the time I
got outside all these guys were gone but
I knew that the broad had set me up
so I waited a few months and I set her
right back up she end up getting to her
cheekbones busted she got her leg busted
her out her elbow busted like four of
her front teeth knocked out they drugged
her for like about 15 feet on the side
of car you know she was really messed up
but she had set me up the same fashion
because you know I was doing a lot of
[ __ ] out there and putting in a lot of
work in other hoods and I was like on
the top of their list - you took in care
of they were rolling around saying they
killed me already I mean like four
different times they say ain't you dead
I thought the guy she was on so
killed you and I was like and they're
saying they'd kill me I'm right here
million killed nobody but it was just
the fact that I used to synchronize and
go to a certain hood I make it like five
times a day no your average guy would go
maybe once or twice I would go five
times a day all Jews today I was in them
at 6:00 in the morning 12 now afternoon
3:00 and afternoon 6:00 in the evening
and midnight I would just hit him left
and right I'll go I go I go and mainly I
go and then we had the master key to all
Toyota Celica from 87 all the way to 90
we had the master key and the master key
you just open the door same key for the
door and the ignition so we never pulled
the ignition we just had a shoebox and
keys and before we left the house one or
two keys it would stick them in the
pocket if we got stranded way over there
far away we just walked down the street
look for a Celica didn't matter what it
looked like we'd get in it the keys open
the door
start the mission it would be gone I
mean I stole so many Philly all the
static closed record yeah that it was
pitiful that's how I learned how to
drive a stick shift was by Bernie make
three clutches but I learned I was only
13 years old and I'm always driving a
stick shift I remember I stole this one
Celica it was so nice one time and we
were walking from far and I told my
homegirl you know what I must do this
car right here so handed stealing the
car we all got in and I remember I got
to a stoplight and a cop is the lights
behind me boom and I told my it was me
my homegirl my homeboy my homework
longer I'm home with six of us in the
live of Celica in my home grocery they
were pretty big girls you know they were
it would call the cheeseburger sister so
you could imagine there were big ass
[ __ ] and they they used to be the
guerrilla gang because they used to beat
guys up you know me so they're in the
car companies behind me here's the
lights I hit the gas boom so we're going
down the Main Street
we're coming up to a red light I tell my
homing homegirls Doug I'm running this
red light so everybody I hit like six
red lights every time I came to red
all I would do was hit the gas jug head
down and go through the red light
without even looking I did that for six
lights I remember we came all the way
from Uptown Whittier
all the way to Norwalk and there's
nothing but we hit nothing but red
lights but I stopped for no lights at
all I just as soon as we're gonna call
it to the intersection I was just tell
everybody to get down and out from my
head down it would just go straight
through I didn't want to see no car
coming to hit me nothing so we went
through six lights when England's
happening is I'm coming down the street
and there's me there's little streets
cutting off to the side so what happens
is I want to cut down one of these
little streets and get away but as I
turn the car to cut down this street
to my left there's so much weight in the
car that the car locks up and I slide up
a curve into a feed store where they
sell chickens rabbits
I killed the Ganga rabbits killed the
Ganga chickens because I wouldn't side
the feed store when I'm sweating inside
the feed store I remember coming to the
car smoking in everything my home world
is leaned over the dashboard on top of
the hood my homey seen shouting hands or
cracking his forehead I hit both my
knees right here hit my chest on that
steering wheel so we grabbed my homegirl
from the hood and we pour her back glass
and everything we pull her back when we
pull her back she has a good like about
this long all when the top of her head
is just open I remember looking at her
and she tells me run homie run and I'm
oh [ __ ] so I grab my gun from the bottom
of the seat I climb on top at the driver
window and I take out running I remember
I'm running and I stashed behind this
lady's wall so I'm listening to see what
I'm here I'm breathing hard I'm trying
to control my vehicle I'm so tired from
running from the cops but then I hear
like a nun you hear
[ __ ] I remember there being a dog
anywhere near swipe fee I like that what
is it
it's a canine I see the cop right behind
him and it's a big-ass German Shepherd
so I take off run the opposite way the
only thing I can hide under I see a UPS
van so I get under the UPS man and I
know the UPS van and here comes the dog
I see him coming I'm like oh [ __ ]
boy that misses the dog rides right up
to the UPS man looks dead at me and then
starts running around the UPS man now I
found out afterwards that the reason the
dog didn't come and get me is because he
could no longer smell my scent
I guess the feelings from the UPS van
being running he could smell my scent
all the way to where you ran up but I'm
telling you I'm laying in the UPS man
and he's looking directly at me I'm
think he's gonna combine my face no he
runs around that runs around the PS van
when he gets to that corner I run out
the other way
so I'm running and I hear I'm running
out of driveway and I hear him right
behind me I can hear his nails eating
the ground like you know like a horse
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I go into a
backyard and there's a fence in a wall
I kind of the fence I grab the wall
picked myself up he tried to jump and
get me he can't jump that wall so I'm
like I'm good
well when I jump down the wall from the
other side when I landed mind you when I
hit the steering wheel my got in the
dashboard hit both my knees and spit up
so when I hit the grass I fell to the
ground boom now I couldn't I don't know
my lady's head went out it gets from the
impact of the crash so I'm in this
backyard you hear the dog bark working
on the other side then I hear him
barking anymore so I'm dragging myself
through the grass
well my homie that was sitting shotgun
he had ran the other way I guess when we
ran I ran this way he ran that way but
we circled around and met up in the same
backyard the one I was dragging myself
through so my homie came out of the
bushes he like what's wrong I took my
camera I can't walk help me out stash me
somewhere you know so he grabbed me he
pulled me he put me under the pool table
in somebody's backyard in their patio
I wanted a pool table and I remember
I'm trying to catch my breath playing
and then all the sudden through that
blue tarp the dog just busted through
boom and grab me my mom mmm so he
started biting my arm and I remember he
was by Tamar man I'm looking and he's
just pulling my skin you know all these
holes on my arm right here all these are
from k9 you know so he's biting me he's
biting me so after you tried to bite me
on my neck I put my hand up you fit me
one time in this hand well we've been in
this hand I grabbed him by his snout but
its nose and top teeth and then I
grabbed his bottom teeth and I was just
gonna try to rip his mouth because they
already had bit me numerous times you
know he he hit me all this song me like
three time in his arm almost leaking
everywhere I had those blood everywhere
but as soon as I grabbed him and I was
gonna rip his mouth open
I remember leave my dog alone him hit me
in back of the head knocked me out on
the cement floor that I was on under by
the side of the pool table when I came
to I hear the cop asking me what my
homey was no my homie mind you was like
in this garage door right here because I
was in the patio he went in the garage
door left me under the pool table wall
as soon as he was asking me for my money
he had the canine and snapping at my
face now I was in handcuffs some lady
comes out of her house that owns that
house and she tells the cop leave him
alone he's just a child I was only 14
years old so I could imagine how small I
looked through all these grown man with
a dog biting the [ __ ] out of me so I
didn't give up my mommy what does he do
he lets the dog go on me again so now
the dog bites my leg tells me to bingo
holes in my leg because I couldn't do
anything I was handcuffed
so he's I'm screaming at the top of my
lungs man I'm asking begging him to get
the dog off me
finally about five minutes three four
five minutes later another dog comes
through the gate he's on my home and
scent so I'm home he scream hear me
screaming and yelling the dog runs up to
the door I can hear my homie on the
other side of the door saying I'm coming
out too late when he opened that door
that dog jumped up hit him in his chest
my mommy fell and I heard my homies
I've never heard a man scream like that
in my life that dog beat the [ __ ] out
and tore up both his legs well you know
the one thing my mommy told me when we
got busted because they took us to the
General Hospital they put us on the 13th
floor to jail ward first he took us to
the Pico hospital fixed it up then they
send us to jail ward in a USC the
general hospital a dumb son general and
they put us in the 13th floor in the
jail ward you had to be 16 years old
enough to go in the jail we're pushing
the jail Ward iron my homie left over
and leaned over and looked at me and
said man you didn't even give me up and
that dog was biting you he said I
wouldn't give you up if that already bit
me whoever invited me I would've told me
exactly who you were at looking for
Johnny you never told him where I was
that see I wasn't even tripping at my
home he was in the garage and he can
hear everything cuz they kept asking me
where's your home he was younger I
didn't give him up they let the dog go
in the bog started biting either stretch
me where's your homie and I didn't know
I knew where he was but remember I was
school a long time going not to ever
tell on anybody in general don't sign
those papers don't talk to nobody just
and I remember when he told me that it
was you didn't even break down when they
had the canine biting you and I was like
nah I wasn't gonna break so what
happened was I couldn't sue him or
nothing because there were people
sheriffs they let the dog go I got a
high pursuit chase after a shooting they
try to put the shooting and me together
a high-speed chase I wrecked my home
goes didn't personal charges one broke
her pelvis in the back she limps today
another one has a big wuss car on her
forehead but my older brother ended up
marrying their older sister so they're
part of the family but that was one time
when you know the cops chased me take
the canines on me and I knew they were
paying for keeps then you don't mean I
knew that it was on and poppin you know
after that if I seen a cop holed up with
a k-9 in his car I wasn't trying to run
no I will you tried you can't outrun a
dog you know especially a canine if
they're on your scent they'll cut
through anything they will climb walls
no I did camp time for that I went to
camp for that and then my uncle went
can't be the year mother Hungary did a
year and I did nine lesson camp for that
alone you know they tried to get me from
the shooting they couldn't place it the
time was messed up so they just got me
for the GTA but I already had seven
GTA's prior I had a total of eleven
GTA's when I went to Canada garden oh
yeah oh yeah we had the mastercard to
toyota celica so we stand we should
steal all of them some of them would be
run down you know in cheap some would be
nice s cards which systems you know we
found so many teams inside every thumb
guns inside them
we found dope inside them money inside
of you know we've all kinds of power
tools you know everything you could
think of inside a car you know i mean we
should take these cars and we just take
everything out of them use them to go do
some shootings and then leave the car
there i reversed
how many clutches you know it was
beautiful you know yeah what happen was
the guy came in shot with a thirty
thirty and those bullets are like three
and a half inches long and my
grandfather when you say look through
the hole in the front yard and i can see
the dogs in the backyard claimed he made
it sarcastically but you can actually
see all the way to the backyard and my
house sits down here and there was a
hill that comes down so the guy shot
from an angle the same guy i went broke
his windows and shot at him the day
before the previous day but before that
day he went and broke all my on both
windows so it was as he broke my
homegirls window she came to me and told
me i went and broke his window shot at
his house and then the following day he
came a shot at my house well that's the
day my grandfather found out that I was
doing the dirt and as he was talking
[ __ ] hitting me I remember Taran I just
read your paper like you do every
morning cuz he just tell me what
what are you gonna do about it I just
read my page just read the paper every
morning while about a month later I
remember my grandma getting his paper
handed the paper now mind you I've been
home for like three days I ain't went
nowhere so he gets his paper he's
looking he's reading it and I remember
he stops he looks up at me and it's done
it's paper he drops his paper and he
never talked to me again ever
and my grandmother my grandfather raised
me my little brother you know he just
never spoke with me ever while I went to
prison in the court he went to every
court date but he never spoke with me he
never spoke to me not a word I guess my
grandfather was upset because he
actually felt that I was the one that
wasn't out there hurting people shooting
people but they didn't know I was the
main one but when he found out he blamed
himself because he remembers the day
that he took me and showed me the bullet
holes in his house and told me that I
wants to do his [ __ ] about it so when he
read his paper and you looked I mean he
put two and two together and my
grandmother told me after years that he
was acting like that that the reason you
talk because he felt that it was his
fault that I ended up the way I ended up
because I was him sitting in prison and
he felt that it was his fault when she
wasn't his father at all always gonna go
back anyways that was one thing we're
gonna go back and forth back and forth
till one of us hadn't come back home or
but the thing about it was is that now
and remember these two shooting him out
thirty
it's going through every wall so he's
not going to get somebody so I end up
getting this dude putting him in the
hospital and he never came back again I
think I see no previous like 10 years
ago and he walks on that stuff you know
I mean he got shot really really bad you
know he is the one that I'm a pop lock
on the floor what I mean by pop lock is
I had a 22 rifle that shot 38 rounds and
there were 22 bullets and we when you
hit somebody hitting so much that they
actually reflect the pop locking because
you're just shaking everywhere
you know and I said it's coming from pop
lock and I used to make food like to
hook him up and watch a guy pop lock you
know and then we need to ground you get
him on ground now the breakdancing
because they spinning you know a lot of
people would spin you know so we would
clown like that and say hey miss
goodnight somebody popped up and I
remember I had that 22 rifle I sold the
front of it off it had a banana clip 38
rounds I remember I used to be there my
finger used to get tired from just
pulling the pull unit and I had that 22
rifle for life oh [ __ ] like two years I
had it and it saved my life a lot of
times he got me a lot money you know it
was like right there at the right time
all the time I never got a cop with it
yeah Glen and oh I hated trading it for
somebody for it for another guy you know
because I used to go like all the way to
content and trade those guys for their
guns beach to trade burns
I just gave all my hot [ __ ] in there you
know they're hot [ __ ] so if we got
caught down here in South East LA wasn't
that's wanted over there in
south-central well they're not gonna
place this with anything over there
because we got it over here so we used
to trade with guys every month we should
do it I used to having like clockwork
you know we used to trade it where dude
used to come when like four of them I'll
trade him for four four
you know and it didn't matter would make
it was there anything just for for for
energy matter how many murders dad on
the gun how many shootings it had that
didn't matter
we were just trading and I was doing
that with the guy from East LA with the
guys from ftv and I got that idea for
one of my homies that I looked up to
he was one of my most treacherous homies
I had you know and he was the only one
that could come in get our children here
after I
used it because once I used it I didn't
want to give it up but he said set my
home had become and get it for me
because he was the only one that can get
it for me you know I wasn't giving it up
that was just the way it was I'm not
gonna go play something in your hand
that I used next weekend because they'll
catch you with it but they're gonna link
you back to me because nine times out of
ten more people are gonna say what the
cop wants to hear when they have them in
that interrogation room I've been
slapped I've been spit at I've been
grabbed by my throat or grabbed by my
hair yeah by the cops in the
interrogation room you know because I
wouldn't say nothing you know me when I
was a youngster I remarried arrested and
I said a few words and the cop changed
everything up made me look like the bad
guy so I knew now when I got arrested no
matter what it was for I ain't got a
word to say nothing I mean some of those
cops would get mad those detectives and
then you actually grab me by your throat
and grabbing burger mouth you know I
mean I try to choke you on a chair you
know and I know somebody's looking for
that glass but the Italian is grown man
and stop whooping I'm here I'm like 15
16 years old and this dude's putting
hands on me I knew something was wrong
but at the same something they wanted my
family me and my brothers so bad because
we were doing so much [ __ ] that they
just couldn't paint it they couldn't
place it but they knew that we were
coming out that house and were selling a
lot of drugs
bulu another words worth making the hood
thrive you know because we're just doing
it there was a lot of us like total 15
of us you know my cousin my cousins then
we're all from the hood so you know I
was never short without a homie you know
I mean I always had a cousin he's my
homeboy you know we went to school here
I had a my cousin brother with me or my
brother going with me so I was never
really alone until that one time when I
was alone out there for the summer and
that was the most treacherous time in my
life you know I did so much [ __ ] that
summer where you know we didn't even
tell me anymore they used to just come
drop me off announcing dope trade the
guns and just mean it wouldn't
over here you ladies ask old mother
homies and I'd be sitting by myself
just listening to him because they
couldn't tell me [ __ ] because I was
doing more than half my homies are
already from the hood putting work when
they were youngsters already had
surpassed them I went way past them you
know and my hood was very very what you
call their area on line their rules we
had certain rules
we couldn't get a frog on our skin
that's we earned it first you know when
we put the hood we didn't put no click
we just put the hood no click you know
we're made to not say anything anybody
not just spread no kind of rumors not to
talk about anybody know not to say
anybody's a rat without having black and
white never put any type of blame on
anybody in this we had paperwork in
front of us and you couldn't be from my
hood unless you were raised and bred in
and raised there or you had family
members other than that you couldn't be
from a hood and it was so family
orientated that it was just families and
we're all from the same hood but I'm
talking about moms kids and then their
kids you know we went generations
so we're embedding with everything my
uncle's had all my uncles I've been a
prison already they already had out
drugs you know me
on the hood so we just stepped right in
and we're laced up as we went along I
mean we had the best threads man i
memorize keep used to see me dressed all
Balinese you like the [ __ ] did you get
that close you know and I wouldn't tell
him once my uncle [ __ ] I would tell him
how I went about it in styling but it
was passed down for my uncle's you know
charlie brown shirts people khakis you
know penton's you know they gave us
women [ __ ] that you know my grandmother
couldn't help but going through the swap
at the next time I'm saying just grab
what you want you know because it
wouldn't matter if she would bias to
what we what she would want us to wear
and my uncles would see us to see you're
not wearing that
here wear this me so you can give us
others [ __ ] in I mean we I felt good so
that's how that be so Bonnaroo where I'd
be the center of attention and I loved
it
you know I mean they were like what do
you get these clothes at my uncles they
just had food cuz its food you know I
mean they each did I don't think I wore
the same thing once a month I had so
much thing you know there's so many
other things that you know I did with
them you know I that I'll show it you
know my uncle took me out missions you
know they took me on my first mission to
earn my turn draw I was only 40 minute
be 15 and they showed me the D before I
did the deed you know he showed me the D
because they did you know my older
brother did the deed couldn't handle it
got off the gang right when he did it he
did it changed up from being this guy
that was treacherous and to be me got
another straight [ __ ] and disrespected
I guess he couldn't handle the beat he
did what he had to do anything he felt
bad about it
you know you guys for the next time yeah
I'll give that one tell you I've got
some issue for you man all the time some
good [ __ ]
you